welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and venom let there be carnage
released a trailer with eddie brock's
prison pal cletus cassidy carnage
in a movie set in sony's mcu uh that is
mrs chen
universe well i guess it's her universe
until venom cookie monsters her
c is fortune lady your face looks so
yummy
stock that chocolate so it looks like
andy circus tried to scoop us with a
director breakdown but where
circus held back on revealing too much i
have come through this trailer frame by
frame to find all the clues he might not
have wanted me to find
spoiler warning in case any of my
theories are right but if not i don't
care because it's more fun to be
surprised we open in san francisco eddie
brock's home where eddie wrote
rules no eating people apparently the
only rule under this roof since they
established it at the end of the first
film
you cannot just go around eating anybody
that you want to
i cannot no you cannot it's written on
the back of a pizza box maybe even
sodini's the restaurant they were headed
to when eddie made that rule but notice
how covering the flat are a whole bunch
of m
ms you see a bag on the bridge a bag on
the chair little baggies all over the
ground also a dispenser it looks like by
the coffee
since venom's favorite foods other than
people are chocolate and tater tots
live chickens roam around could ever
have too many eggs there's one on the
coffee table picking out a magazine
it's a bit hard to tell but it's red and
yellow cover does kind of look like that
magazine of stan lee that venom later
adjusts on mrs chen's stand
he sings along with the music of let's
call the whole thing off originally from
the 1937 ginger rogers fred astaire film
shall we dance music by georgian ira
gershwin is just pairing eddie and venom
as a sort of odd couple
struggling to talk but then realizing
they're essentially thinking the same
thing oh and a
nasty boy alert here but as eddie pours
the oj where is venom
wiping on eddie like i'm pretty sure it
goes under his bathrobe behind his
backside
that's a booty hole like wherever the
venom arm is coming out of maybe he made
a mess
and he's having some courtesy to mop up
after himself i'm saying i've had worse
roommates but before we continue thanks
to rage shadow legends for sponsoring
this video
rage out of legends has a whole world of
amazing looking champions from 14
different factions each with their own
lore
use the links below to download raid
yourself to your mobile phone or pc
one of great's factions are the banner
lords basically medieval knights all
righteous and covered in cool armor
they're down on their luck after wars
with the non-human orcs and skinwalkers
but they're looking to take back their
land by
swinging some gnarly looking weapons to
do so my favorite band of lords champion
is the stag knight one of the most
useful champions in the game despite
having some pretty impractical horns
coming out of the helmet i'm a big fan
of gearing champions like you tweak the
weapon or boots on a champion to change
their
stats and how they work in the pvp or
pve battles and ray just released an
insane amount of new content there's 11
new champions and almost 200 brand new
missions to complete with an exclusive
legendary champion as your reward if you
finish them all
raid also added five tough new levels to
almost every single dungeon in the game
raid's getting bigger and better every
single month and it's never been easier
to get started and on top of the
champions i've talked about already
there's just a whole bunch of other
goofballs that you can play with
like silly and the lucky here think he's
irish dude even took the time to get
like four banana leaves in that helmet
so what are you waiting for go to the
video description click on my links to
support my channel by downloading
braided day
once you're in you can find me in-game
under the name newrock2020 when you play
all your rewards will be waiting for you
here and folks it really is that easy to
play just click the link in the
description and i'll see you in the game
it's important to note that venom is
using a knife to chop up those mushrooms
as opposed to sharpening his own tendril
for one more sanitary but also
andy serkis notes one of the things that
distinguishes carnage
is his ability to shape-shift his
molecular structure into
mist into knives and other weapons which
puts venom at a disadvantage
another little detail i like how venom
tucks eddie's chair in
as if this is all a romantic meal and he
doesn't want eddie to make too much of a
mess on himself also he spilled what
looks like a handful of advil for eddie
on the table by his coffee because this
might be a bit painful but check out
what eddie is holding in his hand that
is a postcard with red writing on it
and later the shots of cletus cassidy in
prison show him starting to write this
same postcard
addressed to eddie brock using ink that
i'm pretty sure is his own
blood at least basing on him writing
welcome eddie and his dada-est arterial
spray in the venom post-credits scene so
cletus cassidy is the serial killer from
the ravel comics who becomes carnage
after sharing a prison cell with eddie
brock and gets latched onto by an
offshoot of the venom symbiote fusing
with cassidy's sadistic deranged mind to
become
carnage arguably the most violent and
disgusting spider-man villain when he
was a kid cletus
tortured and killed pets he murdered his
grandmother he burned down his orphanage
like they don't have enough problems
that orphanage was called saint estes
home for boys and we may actually see
that burning orphanage
later in the trailer so just imagine
that mind with
a symbiote enhancement and you get the
monster who slaughters people in times
square takes over small towns and
murders children in bathtubs
yeah i know now andy circus says this
sequel is set a year and a half
after the first film and that cassidy
allowed only eddie to interview him
because he saw a similarity between them
and now it looks like cassidy's mailing
eddie at his home
meaning he knows his home address with
these creepy bloodletters
and if cletus's blood from this card
fuses with the venom symbiote
and then gets toted back into prison on
a visit that could be how carnage is
born
and venom sprays eddie with ketchup or
shadowing the bloodshed or at least the
bloody red mess of carnage that awaits
him
also staining that golden state warrior
shirt and turning eddie into a detroit
lions fan
interesting mix there so you'll note
that the title card reads
in association with marvel which is how
the 2018 predecessor opened see unlike
spider-man movies produced by sony venom
and carnage are not
in the mcu it looks like but they are
marvel characters whose film rights are
owned by sony and they could still
appear or at least get referenced in
movies like spider-man no way home which
remains a joint production between sony
and marvel that sony is still at the end
of the day calling all the shots on
eddie greets mrs chen whom he saved at
the end of the first film and if you
think about it had a relatively calm
reaction to seeing a man get eaten
and now just casually greets venom who
salutes back and yes fixes that stan lee
magazine on the rack remember eddie
passed stan in the previous movie
and now this friendly dog walker is on
magazines as more friendly dog walkers
should be then the camera glides up to
san quentin prison i actually think this
is the same
shot from the 2018 film post-credits
scene and in cassidy's cell
are carved doodles we see a teddy bear
and then underneath that someone
presumably him stick figure form
torturing an animal in a cage i think
with words sweet
death and then to the left of the bear a
figure holding a severed head
and then below all of it the phoenix
will rise
oh my god x-men phoenix he's right
confirmed no no i'm kidding
the x-men are formerly fox now disney
properties not sony one so this is just
cassidy declaring his own return from
the ashes
look right above his desk there's his
stick figure self with his hands up
a gun pointed at him but the bullet
looped
looping over his head missing him
remember set video last year showed
cassidy dancing in the face of gunfire
this is pre-vfx presumably this is gonna
be the carnage symbiote deflecting the
bullets of his head which is similar to
his doodle
it's like carnage is gonna let him do
what he's always dreamed of doing now
most interesting here
the writing on the left is a quote thus
strangely
are our souls constructed and by slight
ligaments are we bound to prosperity and
ruin
this is a quote from mary shelley's
frankenstein it's a ponderance on human
nature's fickle constitution
one improperly placed peace could doom
the soul to a life of evil
referring to the body parts of dead
criminals that victor used to construct
his monster cletus cassidy will
too transform from doomed criminal
practically a corpse
to a supernatural monster in rage
cassidy punches the wall if you look
there there's a bunch of crosses carved
in maybe showing a cemetery
similar to the final battle setting and
maximum carnage which seems like one of
the big influences on this story but
then the other shot peering into the
cell fetus has carved a tree with
something
underneath maybe the location of one of
his victims in fact a lot of this stuff
could be confessions of the different
people he's killed and the way he's
killed them
beneath the tree branch there is some
writing that looks like where they
cannot kill and then at the bottom
you'll have to do something about it but
then to the right
himself in a cage above a tombstone that
says hell
for vanished children with a ton of
little faces underneath
sweet death and then we're right there
looks like there's a little church there
similar to the drawing that eddie has in
his finals showing a church with one
little figure
which could be cassidy drawing a
childhood memory from the church on the
grounds of saint estes
on eddie's laptop is a daily bugle front
page reading the mind of serial killer
cletus cassidy telling us that eddie's
article is written in the daily bugle
longtime employer of peter parker but
note that the masthead here is the print
edition logo that appeared in the sam
raimi films not the digital
digitaldailybugle.net
infowars design from the mcu in
spider-man far from home andy circus
said that this film is set in its own
world with these characters quote
unaware of spider-man which seems hard
to buy if it's set in the same world as
morbius
with the same daily bugle print logo on
an ad asking where is spider-man and a
movie that features the mcu
vulture someone who previously fought
spider-man either way it just sounds
like circus way of saying
don't expect spider-man in this film
though sony may be introducing us to all
of these villains one by one to
inevitably cross them over into a shared
universe
in a live-action spider-verse maybe
coming as soon as spider-man no way home
or sinister 6 movie beyond that maybe
also this sony
verse will have a live action miles
morales or gwen stacy instead of peter
parker
alternate spider people who just have
not yet emerged yet in this world we see
another daily bugle copy read by this
detective played by steven grant
his name is mulligan which could be a
nod to patrick mulligan aka toxin
a symbiote offshoot from carnage in the
comics that could be mulligan's fate in
this film the mulligan's bugle reads the
hidden victims of cletus cassidy by
eddie brock the only journalist to ever
interview cassidy mulligan seems pissed
that he's getting the access that
mulligan and the feds have been unable
to get in their desperate search for
cassidy's other victims notice how the
corner headline reads
booming tech industry sends people to
the streets reflecting the
gentrification of the san francisco bay
area how the tech industry has priced
many people out of their homes and
contributed to the area's rising
homelessness but also was like this
headline from 2006 because san francisco
has been unaffordable for at least a
decade notice how behind mulligan is a
map of the city with a few dots by the
tenderloin district
that is the area of san francisco
particularly known for its homeless
population
so i am thinking this film will pull
from the absolute carnage storyline in
which carnage takes over
a cult worshiping the symbiote klyntar
deity of
null and carnage creates carnage drones
out of homeless people in san francisco
yeah it's really messed up that's
carnage also behind mulligan is a
booking cheat for
e larson a nod to eric larson comic book
artist
and writer from the 90s spider-man era
who went on to co-found image comics and
as mulligan folds a newspaper many have
spotted text that
looks like the word avengers and
nightmare though i don't think it's
avengers folks it could just as easily
be passengers or scavengers or
messengers
or a guy named angers one of these
things losing a nightmare
something parcel or a sports game a
night of sleep over making too many
mephisto theories overall this cassidy's
voice asks
every decision we ever make who do we
leave behind and how do we leave them
waiting in the darkness for the rescuer
who never comes
and not so suddenly he kills a spider
another sign that spider-man will be a
rescuer who never comes in this movie
though we could also be hearing cassidy
preaching from the pulpit to his
followers addressing the way homeless
people have been feeling left behind in
the darkness
and we visit the ravencroft institute
this is marvel's facility for the
criminally insane known for
experimenting on and imprisoning many
marvel super villains
it was also a setting in the amazing
spider-man 2 where elektra was
experimented on after remember when he
got electrified by those oscorp eels
that's one of the ones they're bringing
back now here in the cell is francis
barrison aka
shriek no i said shriek played by naomi
harris from the bond films
so shriek is a spider-man villain and
companion to carnage known from that
maximum carnage storyline where the two
break out from the ravencroft institute
and go on a killing spree in new york
city
shriek's power is that she can emit
powerful sonic blasts which is why the
guards here are all wearing ear
protection also notice all that sound
proofing on the walls and then the one
in the lab code behind them
could be dr kafka from the comics who
oversees the ravencroft
notice how shriek has a mark over her
eye a nod to the marking over streak's
eye in the comics
so the music for the second half of the
trailer is harry nilsson's amazing one
one is the loneliest number yeah you
know i love this song because nilsson
said that he got the idea of those
cynthia staccato chords
from listening to a phone busy signal so
he recreated this as a c
minor chord which he plays as these kind
of staccato beeps and i love how this
trailer deconstructs those chords
back to their form elongating out the
beats from each other
maybe reflecting our man cletus cassidy
a lonely cut cut-off guy from the rest
of the world
just trying to get in touch with eddie
brock but someone who no longer picks up
the phone
until those phone busy signals just
stretch out and stretch out and stretch
out until this guy
loses it so whether cassidy gets his
symbiote off shoot from those blood
cards or some other fluid exchange with
eddie the carnage symbiote stops his
lethal injection with a little wiggle
ugh shoots out from his arm up the tube
to push back the fluid what a cool way
to show this and then if you look at his
hands it looks like the veins and
capillaries
burst out as micro tentacles of carnage
with the rest of carnage snaking up in a
mist from his face and his shoulders
what a horrible thing to see if you're
one of those victims families another
shot shows two figures walking among the
flames of that burning mansion maybe
carnage and shriek together if this is a
sainesta's home this could be among the
stops on their rampage after escaping
ravencroft and then a shot of streaks
screaming in her cell you can see her
sonic waves blowing everything around
and her breath blasting upward there
i love how her scream reverberates
throughout the trailer it has a
punctuating sound effect
now she seems to be reacting from a
daily bugle and on it you can see the
words cletus cassidy
does something maybe escapes or a
premature headline reading dead
or executed like maybe her guards
delivered this news to her and she's
freaking out mourning him without
realizing that he's actually coming to
break her out because notice the next
shot large red tentacles
of carnage are attacking this suv and
those id covered walls tells us that
this is the raven crop institute that we
see in the other shots oh this must be
where carnage is breaking shriek out
you can see similar tentacles attacking
a helicopter and pulling out the gunner
and then prison guards fire at something
as staff and inmates flee probably
cletus emerging from the execution room
which
andy circus said that he modeled exactly
on the san quentin lethal injection
chamber and then the trailer's money
shot
nice so carnage's design is pretty comic
accurate the veiny claws
and the more slender build than venom
and of course the gnarly tentacles each
one formed into a different
sharpened weapon looks like a mace on
the upper left it's a more
frontward spiky pokers on the right and
i love how that one just kind of oozes
the strand of slime
now they do light him from behind in
both of the shots that we see him
i'm guessing to hide some of the less
finished vfx notice how circus also uses
a shaky cam to mask it all
we can see some scaffolding behind
carnage this is being used to repair a
church interior perhaps the other church
we've talked about
because we close on carnage suspended in
front of a stained glass window a shot
that andy circus called his leonardo da
vinci shot referring to the vitruvian
man
but circus was otherwise reluctant to go
into the shot which is why you need an
independent super nerd to do your
breakdowns because i'll tell ya
churches are important to carnage both
as the climactic setting of the maximum
carnage game
and if this church is a bell tower you
know a place where sonic frequencies
could destabilize the symbiotes but with
a title like let there be carnage
a reference to the book of genesis the
first words god says
we could indeed be looking at some
absolute carnage influences where
carnage mobilizes the homeless of san
francisco as part of his religious cult
elevating himself to a god like the mary
shelley frankenstein quote he etched in
his sprint cell he sees himself
as a formerly inhuman monster who should
be dead
but resurrected as this outcast who
looks down upon mankind comment down
below with your reaction to this trailer
and you can support
this channel by checking out one of our
many great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com you can follow me
on instagram and twitter at eavos
subscribe to
rockstars for breakdowns of everything
marvel thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you